lagarde moi j'ai pas trop aimé le mois
d'août avoir réveillé j'ai pas trop aimé
le téléfilm et puis quand on dit que
c'est une prise de risque de la part de
tf1 d'avoir misé sur une première
comédienne c'est comme avec jennifer
elle est ultra pouvoir a mis un visage
inconnu coiffer supprimés auxquels il
était au cinéma bien sûr mais y aller il
ya l'effet que tous les fans de la
chanteuse qui regardait la télé aussi on
n'avait pas aimé le téléfilm passe pas
spécialement bon vous avez regardé bas à
gérer chaque année un pont henri p j'ai
même pas fini vous allez regarder quoi
les 15 premières minutes elle des cinq
royaumes iront à la catho coup si vous
commencez à mentir ça va être vite
réglée mais j'avoue que j'ai lancé les
nu pieds parce que je savais qu'on
allait en parler ce soir
ouais et j'ai failli tout vous avez vu
combien de temps deux minutes non je
pense 22 minutes a pour 32 minutes sur
le replay les vu que les pubs elle prend
la place d'un chroniqueur qui aurait
peut-être travailler sept corners il
travaillait michel mr n'est pas non plus
un rôle de composition de ouf elle le
fait très bien
voilà mais je trouve qu'un arrêté vous
êtes chose que lille nice l'histoire
était plus importante que les
personnages
pourquoi j'ai parcomètres pourquoi ne
pas reconnaître une fois simplement
qu'elle était vraiment et je fais
d'abord